تختتم في العاصمه الاثيوبيه اديس ابابابا
القمه الافريقيه السادسه والثلاثون بعد ان
بحثت جمله تحديات امنيه واقتصاديه تعيشها
القاره وسط تنافس دولي على النفود السياسي
والاقتصادي والعسكري في ربوعها وقد شهدت
القمه طرد وفد اسرائيلي حاول تمثيل
اسرائيل كعضو مراقب ما اثار الجدل بشان
موقع ودور القوه الخارجيه في القمم
الافريقيه وقضاياها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما حيثيات ودلالات طرد
دبلوماسيين اسرائيليين ومنعهم من المشاركه
باسم اسرائيل في قمه الاتحاد الافريقي كعض
مراقب ما المضامين التي اتخذها الجدل بشان
تاثير القوه الخارجيه في اشغال القمه
الافريقيه وما تطرحه من قضايا القاره وهو
الامر الذي تجلى في اجراءات دول افريقيه
بحق دول كبرى اتهمتها بالتدخل في شؤونها
الداخليه والى ماذا قد يتطور مثل هذا
الجدل المستقبلا بالنظر الى توقعات بان
تعاود اسرائيل محاوله اقتحام القمم
الافريقيه القادمه وكذلك بالنظر الى
علاقات الدول الكبرى بالقاره الافريقيه
وقضايا
[موسيقى]
بحضور اكثر من ثلاثين من الرؤساء ورؤساء
الوزراء اتم الاتحاد الافريقي قمته
السادسه 36 في العاصمه الاثيوبيه
وفيما اوحى شعار القمه بالتركيز على
الهموم الاقتصاديه لم تغب عن اعمالها
مشاغل سياسيه وامنيه ما كان بالوسع
تجاهلها تجاهلها ومن بين اهمها التنافس
الدولي على النفوذ باشكاله المختلفه
بالقاره
اذا هذه الاعمال انتهت هذه القمه عرفت
مشاركه دوليه واسعه ايضا من خلال ممثلين
عن قوه دوليه بارزه فمع الامين العام
للامم المتحده سجل مسؤولون بارزون من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وروسيا
والاتحاد الاوروبي والصين مشاركتهم في
اعمال القمه في تمثيل واسع ونوعي يعكس في
نظر مراقبين الاهميه التي تحوزها القاره
السمراء في خارطه التحالفات ونزاعات
الدوليه المتصاعده في الوقت الراحم
وفي اخر مظاهر التفاعل الجدل الدائري حول
دور القوى الدوليه في القاره وبالتزامن مع
اختتام اشغال قمه الاتحاد الافريقي ها هي
بوركينا فاسو تعلن الانتهاء الرسمي
لعمليات القوات الفرنسيه على اراضيها وكان
مسؤولون في البلاد قد اظهروا من خلال
تصريحات لهم رغبتهم في تقارب اكثر مع
روسيا نناقش هذه المواضيع مع ضيفينا في
الاستوديو الكاتب المختص
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذه هي المواضيع مع الكاتب المختص
في الشؤون الافريقيه والعلاقات الدوليه
مكه المغربي ونور الدين عبد الباحث المختص
في الشؤون الافريقيه ايضا اهلا وسهلا بكم
نبدا بما حدث مع الوفد الاسرائيلي الذي
طرد من القاعه ما الذي نفهمه من هذا اذا
بدات بك استاذ مكي
اعتقد انه
[موسيقى]
طرد المندوبه الاسرائيلي من
قمه افتتاحيه ليس حدث كبير اصلا ولا يعبر
عن الواقع اسرائيل موجوده في القاره
الدوله المضيفه اثيوبيا لديها علاقات مع
اسرائيل بل حتى
السته او اللجنه الثلاثيه التي حددها
الاتحاد الافريقي لبحث قضيه
عضويه اسرائيل كمراقب
هؤلاء السته خمسه منهم لديهم علاقات مع
اسرائيل انا اعتقد ما حدث يمكن ان يوصف
بانه ربك اجرائيه اكثر من كونه انتصار
لقضيه فلسطينيه او غير ذلك اسرائيل واقع
في العالم ومواقع في القاره ويجب التعامل
معه نور الدين عبده يعني ليس حدث كبير هو
حدث كبير انا اعتقد ببساطه لو انه لم يكن
حدثا كبيرا لم يخرج ذلك البيان الغاضب من
الخارجيه الاسرائيليه وحدث قد يكون
اجرائيا هو حدث رمزي لكنه في واقع الامر
يجسد يعني
الفكره الافريقي المتضامن شعبيا ورسميا مع
القضيه الفلسطينيه هناك يعني الام مشتركه
بين الشعوب الافريقيه
والفلسطينيين هناك مبدا درجه عليه القاره
الافريقيه عموما وحتى الان هناك تمسك كبير
يعني الموضوع مثل جدل كبير جدا ليس الان
وانما يعني له سنوات يعني نريد ان نفهم
العلاقه انا يعني اغطي هذه القمه منذ سنه
ست سنوات تقريبا دائما يكون هناك حديث
للرئيس الفلسطيني ومشاركه منتظمه للرئيس
ابو مازن هذه المره كان رئيس الوزراء
تيم محمد شتيم كيف يمكن ان نصف العلاقه
بين الافارقه
والسلطه الفلسطينيه وبالتالي اسرائيل مع
الوضع في الاعتبار ما ذكرته للتو من
المشاركه المنتظمه للسلطه الفلسطينيه انا
اعتقد انه مبدئيا يجب الفصل بين وجود
علاقات دبلوماسيه مع اسرائيل والانحياز
للقضيه الفلسطينيه بدليل ان اكثر الدول
الانحيازا قضيه فلسطينيه جنوب افريقيا
لديها علاقات مع اسرائيل حتى ان مرت بتوتر
سحب سفير او غير ذلك لم تقطع علاقاتها لم
تسحب اعترافها بدوله اسرائيل تركيا
المنحازه للقضيه الفلسطينيه لديها علاقات
مع اسرائيل لذلك يعني الدمجه القضيتين خطا
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه ودوليه لديها مسار
الاتحاد الافريقي ينبغي ان يقرر ما اذا
كانت اسرائيل لديها عضويه مراقبه ام لا
بعيدا عن ان هذا سيؤثر في انحيازه بالقضيه
الفلسطينيه انا اعتقد انه الحديث عن
التضامن بشكله الذي حدث في الستينات فات
عليه الاوان نعم صحيح احنا بنتكلم عن واقع
واقع ان السلطه الفلسطينيه بتشارك بشكل
منتظم الاسرائيلي لما جاء انطرد نعم يعني
الاتحاد الافريقي اولا يعني هو ليست منظمه
دوليه فقط هي منظمه ايضا شعبيه تمثل ضمير
الشعب الشعوب الافريقيه عموما
يعني لذلك التمسك بالقضيه الفلسطينيه هو
من مبادئ الشخصيه
الافريقيه بوجه العموم ومشاركه يعني
الحكومه او السلطه الفلسطينيه عبر منذ
تاسيسها وحتى الان هي مشاركه فعاله وقويه
ونذكر يعني خطاب رئيس الوزراء الفلسطيني
في القمه الماضيه كان خطاب هو حرك جميع من
كانوا في القاعه وكان خطاب مؤثر وهذا
التاثير لم ياتي فقط من فراغ وانما يعني
موجود في كينونه الانسان الافريقي
ربما الخطاب
شديد اللهجه ضد اسرائيل كان لموجابي قبل
وفاته في هذه القمه
يمثل عموما هو يعني في حديث كثير عن
اسرائيل وعن دول اخرى وصراع على النفوس
استاذ مكي كيف ترى هذا
الصراع من دول او قوه كثيره سبعه وزراء من
اوروبا شاركوا هذه المره وطبعا بالاضافه
لمبعوث الروسي والمبعوث الصيني والمبعوث
الامريكي
طبعا هو هذه هي القضيه بينما نشتغل بربكه
اجرائيه وحضور اسرائيل من عدمها والقمه
كلها تتعرض الى انزال دبلوماسي دوليه يعني
يعني ما حدث في هذه القمه الافريقيه انها
مفتوحه على كل القوى التي تتصارع عمليا في
افريقيا
وانا انا لا ادري لماذا لم يكن هنالك حضور
قوي لروسيا حتى حتى تكتمل الصوره يعني
ونكون امام واقع
مبعوث روسي اللي هو
الخاص
بذات الاحجام الكبيره هو موجود طبعا
[موسيقى]
يعني انا من وجهه نظري وهناك ايضا يعني
بحوث كثيره في هذا الاتجاه وهو هل هل نصف
ما يجري الان هو
صراع ام تنافس
وهناك يعني بالنسبه للرؤيا الافريقيه
السائده الان انه هذا هناك تنافس على
افريقيا الجميع يريد ان ان يكون له يعني
موطئ قدم بطريقه اخرى اقتصاديا سياسيا
يكون له مكان وافريقيا ايضا تريد ان تعمل
تدرك هذا الشيء ولا تريد ان تتحول الى
يعني حديقه خلفيه لتصفيه الحسابات والصراع
وللعوده الى الى الى صراعات الحرب البارده
افريقيا واعيه والنخب الافريقيه والزمان
الافريقيون الجدد واعين بهذه القضيه تماما
هم يعني هناك توجه فريقي واضح انه يريد ان
يستفيد من هذا التنافس بالمحافظه على
المصالح الافريقيه والمصالح الوطنيه ودون
الانجرار وراء ما يمكن ان يكون هو يعني
صراع على النف نعم فالمساله تعود في
عمومها الى مدى قدره القاده الافارقه الى
الموازنه بين المصالح بالضبط في النهايه
العلاقات الدوليه مبنيه على المصالح
السؤال الاستاذ مكي يعني حكايه انه يوجد
هناك تنافس محموم على النفوذ هذا لمصلحه
القاره ام هو امر في حقيقه الامر يجب ان
ان يكون هناك تحذير منه كما اشار الاستاذ
نور الدين التي صفى الحسابات على الارض
الافريقيه بين دول عده هذا هو دور الاتحاد
الافريقي وهذا هو الدور الغائب للاتحاد
الافريقي الاتحاد افريقي يجب ان يقود هو
زمام المبادره بدلا من ان يتحول هو نفسه
ساحه للصراع والتجاذب على سبيل المثال اخر
الاخبار ان
بوركينا فاسو دخلت في ضمن الدول الخارجه
من الطوق الفرنسي تماما وترحب بالوجود
الروسي ما الذي يفعله الاتحاد الافريقي
الدول يتحدث بلغه اقرب للدول الغربيه
يتحدث عن ان هنالك دول حدثت فيها تغييرات
غير دستوريه
ويعاقبها وهي تفتح ابوابها لروسيا على
سبيل المثال الدول توجد الان دول غائبه من
القيمه الافريقيه بينما يتحدث الناس عن
هذا الوجود الغربي الكبير وانت من السودان
والسودان يعني انظر الى ما حدث في السودان
عضويه معلقه نعم
السودان ما حدث فيه هو انتهاك صريح لميثاق
الديمقراطيه والانتخابات في الاتحاد
الافريقي الذي ينص على انه يعتبر انقلاب
عسكري
الانقلاب على حكومه ديمقراطيه منتخبه لم
توجد حكومه ديمقراطيه متخبه
السودان مجلس الامن والسلم قال انه لن يتم
التسامح ابدا مع انه يكون هناك انظمه تصل
الى الحكم الصوره غير دستوريه ولكن موسى
فكي قال ايضا ان العقوبات على هذه الانظمه
لم تكن
مجديه استاذ نوره يعني انا سؤالي هو انه
هذه الانظمه التي تعاقب هل
تجبر على فتح احضانها انجاز التعبير للنفذ
الروسي وغيره هو انا لا ارى قراءه الموضوع
في هذا الاطار ابدا يعني والقراءه في هذا
الاطار ربما تاتي من قبل الدول التي وقعت
فيها هذه الانقلابات وهذه المجموعات تريد
ان ان ترى مسوغ معين وتقول نحن اذا
الاتحاد الافريقي ضغط علينا ربما نتجه كذا
ولا كذا ولكن في نهايه الموضوع المهم في
هذه المساله
الانقلابات العسكريه وعدم الاستقرار
السياسي والاستبداد بعمومه هو الذي عانت
منه افريقيا خلال يعني العقود الماضيه منذ
الاستقلال ويعني العمليه الديمقراطيه مهما
كان حتى لو كانت شكليه يجب ان تستمر ويجب
ان ان الشعوب الافريقيه ان تلعب دور وت
يعني تتمرن وتتدرب على الديمقراطيه لتصل
الى مرحله النضوج
الانقلابات العسكريه تقطع هذا الطريق
تماما وهناك يعني بغض النظر عن ان ان
مشاكل العلاقات الدوليه هناك اتفاق على
مستوى النخب على مستوى الساسه في افريقيا
انه يجب ان نقف امام هذه الحاله لانه اذا
جئنا نحن نبرر الانقلابات بانه حتى لا
نرتمي الى الاحضان نبرر لانقلابات بان
الاتحاد الافريقي ضعيف الاتحاد الافريقي
مؤسسه عمرها 60 عاما قطعت شوط جيد نعم
ويعني يجب ان نقرا في اطار التراكمات
في اطار التراكمات و60 عاما من عمل
الاتحاد الافريقي الى اخر ذلك هل تغيرت
نظره القوى الكبرى الى هذه القاره النظره
الاستعماريه التي طالما كان هناك خطاب
ضدها من الافارقه طوال عشرات السنين هل في
تعامل مختلف الان
انا اعتقد التعامل الاسوا بل انا اعتقد
انه احيانا هذه الدول تؤثر في قرار
الاتحاد الافريقي على سبيل المثال ما حدث
في السودان ما حدث في السودان حتى بعد
تعليق العضويه
جاره اتفاقيه بين قائد الجيش والرئيس
الوزراء المدني عبد الله حمدوك لم يرفع
الاتحاد الافريقي تعليق العضويه بسبب ان
هنالك قوه خارجيه لا ترغب في تكوين حكومه
مستقلين كما يعني
احنا بنسال عن حكايه انه استغلال الثروات
ونهب الثروات كما كان يقول الافارقه وهذه
النظره للاستعلائيه الى غير ذلك هذا مستمر
متغير اولا يعني هذا الموضوع يعني هو جزء
من موروث تاريخي من فتره الاستعمار قد لا
يكون تغير مئه في المئه على المستوى
النفسي والذهني والفكري بالنسبه
للانسان الاوروبي والغربي عموما لكن على
مستوى الوعي السياسي والتفاعل السياسي
غربيا هناك تغير كبير جدا في هذا الاتجاه
كيف يعني ما يحصل الان وبفضل التنافس
الدولي على افريقيا وبفضل ايضا هناك يعني
قدر كبير جدا من محاولات افريقيه
للاستفاده من هذا التنافس نرى ان
الاوروبيين يعني في قمه
القمه الافريقيه الاوروبيه قمه
الطاوله المستديره الطرحه الاساسي هو ان
يكون التعامل بشكل مختلف قمه الافريقيه
الامريكيه كان هذا الكلام وهي قمه كانت
الهدف الاساسي منها لازاله فجوه الثقه
وفجاه فجوه التواصل بين
الافارقه والعالم الغربي هناك نظره مختلفه
والغربيون يعني
مضطرون لهذه للتغيير سلوكهم هل هل تغيرهم
هل ما يحدث مع فرنسا دليل على ذلك حضرتك
اشرت لبروركينا فاسو قبل ان كانت هناك
مالي
والنيجر وبوركينا فا دائما يعني
تعبر عن رغبتها في التقارب من روسيا ما
الذي يحدث مع فرنسا التي كانت موجوده بقوه
في القرن الافريقيه تاريخيه للاسف القوى
الغربيه هي تحاول التدخل في افريقيا
والناس يعتقدون انها قوه ذكيه وعاقله فات
الاوان هذا التدخل الغربي للاسف ياتي ضد
المصالح الغربيه نفسها وهذه دائما رسالتنا
للغربيين انكم انتم الذين تفتحون ابواب
افريقيا للصين وروسيا
بمنهج العقوبات وبالتدخل وبالضغط على
الاتحاد الافريقي وغير ذلك الذي حدث الان
عباره عن فراغ امني كبير الفراغ الامني
ستملئه روسيا والشركات الروسيه سواء شئنا
ذلك ام ابينا انا لا ارغب في ذلك ولا ولا
روسيا ستملاه روسيا ايضا سنتحدث عن الصيد
نعم عمليا الان روسيه تتمدد لدينا لدينا
افريقيا الوسطى افريقيا الوسطى هي عباره
عن سوريا
باعتبار انه تحت الشركات
الامنيه الروسيه
وتواديرا هو يشكل بشار اسد افريقيا
باعتبار انه محمي بصوره مباشره من الروس
هل كان هذا الامر موجود قبل خمس سنوات غير
موجود ما هو السبب هو سياسات الغربيه ما
هو دور الاتحاد الافريقي انا اعتقد دورا
الاتحاد الافريقي بدلا من ان يوعي الغرب
ويصل معه الى اتفاقيات افضل لصالح القاره
صار هو ايضا
ممر للتدخل القوه الاكبر وهي الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه نور الدين عبده اين هي
من كل هذا
يعني كانت الولايات المتحده خلال يعني عقد
تقريبا تغيبت عن افريقيا بشكل كبير جدا
وهناك سعي كبير لادراك ان ان الصين خلال
هذه الفتره ثم بعدها روسيا ايضا استطاعت
ان تتمدد في المنطقه بشكل كبير واستطاع ان
تحصل على قدر كبير جدا من التواجد
فامريكا الان تسعى بقدر كبير الى استعاده
دورها
ويعني ورص صفوف المجموعات والدول التي
تساندها ومتحالفه معها
والقمه الافريقيه الامريكيه كانت في هذا
الاتجاه وكانت هناك وعود كبيره ولكن يعني
ربما
تعاني يعني او او يعني الولايات المتحده
تستطيع ان تستفيد بقدر كبير جدا من من
القوه الناعمه لانه في النهايه يعني مهما
يكون هناك تنافس من الصين ومن من روسيا
وقوه اخرى يكون هذا التنافس في الاتجاه
الاقتصادي افريقيا تحتاج الى اختصاصيه
يعني نوعا هي في صالح امريكا لكن
غائبه امريكا ليس كذلك مقارنه الحد الكبير
امريكا غائبه هي تجتهد صراحه تجتهد اجتهاد
واضح في العوده الى افريقيا او في الدخول
هي لا نتحدث عن عوده لان اصلا لم تكن
موجوده
اوروبا موجوده اكثر منها الصين اصلا
موجوده بوصي كان موجوده
الان تحاول ان تدخل ولكن انا ايضا اعتقد
انها
لا تدخل بسياسات موفقه حتى الان
بدليل انه لم تكتسب اصدقاء حقيقيين على
ارض الواقع في القاره الافريقيه ما زال
القرار الامريكي مشلول باختصار الصين حتى
المبنى الذي نحن في هذا الكبير الاتحاد
الافريقي هديه من الصين
[موسيقى]
تسمح لهم صراعات كثيره صحيح ان الامكانيات
الماديه وتعقيدات المشكله الافريقيه ربما
تظهر ان الافارقه ليسوا فطنين لذلك لكن في
كينونتهم فطنون جدا وهم عاملون على ذلك
يعني بذكاء افريقي
شكرا ده حلوه ذكاء افريقي شكرا جزيلا لك
البحث المختص الشرقيه نور الدين عبده
وايضا مكه المغربي الكاتب المختص في شؤون
الافريقيه والعلاقات الدوليه شكرا جزيلا
لكم مشاهدينا الكرام بهذا ناتي الى نهايه
هذه الحلقه من ما وراء الخبر جاءتكم من
مقر الاتحاد الافريقي في تغطيتنا هذه
للقمه الافريقيه في العاصمه الاثيوبيه
اديس الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]